when you moved out here did you have a
strategy because you talked about
graduating from the conservatory and
they did this showcase and kind of mmm
in the dark of it when you came out here
you'd been in New York did you have a
specific game plan yeah as sub-sub least
a room and West Hollywood in a house and
I knew I was gonna be there for at least
six months and then have to look for you
know a different place I had also spoken
to a guy I went to school with who's a
couple years older than me who lives out
here and was an agent at the time and he
was the only person I knew but sort of
like nah I mean he was more of an
acquaintance than you know a friend but
um and he had mentioned to go take
Leslie Khan's comedy intensive so I knew
okay that's how I want to be I know I'm
gonna be thrown and right away and to
on-camera comedy class and I did and
that was like nine years ago and to this
day I'm still friends with like half of
the people in that class like I still
you know talk to them that was sort of
like my instant group of friends and
because you have to rehearse every night
for a few hours a night so you kind of
become your own like ensemble but I
highly recommend that I still tell
people to do that whether you just do it
once you don't have to keep going to the
ongoing you know if you don't want to
but at least do that when you first move
to LA it's great what were some of the
things that were sort of curveballs that
you weren't used it you know you'd kind
of plan it you'd gotten this sublease
and you had sort of this traffic what
were some of the things that threw you
for a loop a little bit that now you
know you would have done like whatever
save up three months rent or whatever oh
I wouldn't have done that different cuz
I know myself and if I was like using
the excuse of money like cuz I didn't
have that much money at all you never
did when I went to New York never did
here you know is I would not under me
and I wouldn't him like that would have
been really hard to save that much money
before I could go it's just not the way
I operate a lot of people can you know
they have to operate that way but I got
a job
the like a part-time temp you know
office job or whatever the second day I
was here so I'd already made calls I
mean tons of calls before to see like
what kind of job I could do and so
auditions and also had a meeting set up
with an agent here who had contacted me
and let's see I had a lot of what do you
say Stokes and the fire I'd had just a
running list things and then what I was
gonna do about a car cuz gosh you know
like I'd not driven a car since high
school because I lived in cities the
whole time so there was no need for a
car and I remember one night laying in
bed going what am i doing what are you
doing yeah dry like on an interstate
freeway it's a little scary yeah so that
part was a little bit creepy I guess but
I mean it was fine I just did a renter
wreck for a couple months and I just
feel like you just make it work like I
just made it work on what I could afford
at the time and so when I got the job
and you know you you start to have more
of a sense of like stability and routine
especially with that acting class to
like I need that to feel same yeah
there's been a lot of talk like should
people have a plan B did they convey
that to you during schooling or no yeah
yeah they did talk about it I mean some
people were very some of our instructors
are like you're gonna look around your
class and ten years from now somebody's
gonna choose to be a mommy instead or
somebody's gonna choose to go back to
school and you know get get a master's
degree in something else
somebody's gonna shoot you know a
thousand different things but I
I've never believed in that for myself I
don't understand having a plan B because
first of all I'm single I have you know
I don't have any kids I mean I don't
have anybody else that I need to provide
for or I need to answer to so having a
plan B just seems like I don't know like
a lazy for me would be a lazy way for an
some sort of escape to I don't know what
because there's not like something else
I want to be doing necessarily but so
that was definitely something that they
advise hmm yeah and even when I was
taking a few classes in New York I
remember with this one manager and she
would do
like it was like an audition prep class
one of those millions of different
classes you take in New York and her
saying she's really kind of nasty about
it you know like um probably only two of
you in this class of 20 is actually
gonna you know do anything with this so
just look around remember that some of
you probably do need to have a plan B so
how did you feel about that kind of
advice because some people I think and
appreciate it and some it's really
off-putting
yeah and summarizes the challenge I
thought it was kind of funny I mean it
was also like I could acknowledge it was
kind of nasty but it was also kind of
truthful I mean if you think of the odds
of who's gonna you know stay with this
day-in day-out and not go a different
you know course so did she say why I'm
curious did she give a reason why people
don't stay with it well she would so you
know this is just hard you know it's
hard a lot of people don't have the grit
or whatever to stay with it it's what
she is saying so it sounds like you
planned what you didn't do it were you
obsessively worried about what's gonna
happen in four months do am I gonna be
me so so there was like a part of you
that's a planner and then part of you
that's more spontaneous yeah I mean I
did like I kept my apartment for two
years so a couple of my friends here
we're like I guess you have a problem
with commitment like do you have a
commitment issues like no I just think
that's the wise thing for me to do
because it's hard enough to find an
apartment in New York you know in
Manhattan that you I can afford and
everything and to keep my stuff there I
didn't bring any furniture and you I
just live out here so that to me was
maybe the plan B would be oh go back to
New York and go back you know to working
in theater there
you